parler on retrouve en direct michel
abhervé professeur d'économie sociale et
de politiques publiques il ya donc
blogueur sur le site
alternatives économiques au bonjour
michel abhervé merci d'être avec nous
alors pourquoi les jeunes sont ils les
plus touchées dans cette crise tout
simplement parce qu'il rentrait du
travail à une époque où le marché du
travail en conséquence de la crise offre
peu de possibilités pour y rentrer et
donc il faut toucher parce que c'est le
moment d'en laure du professionnel où
ils ont vomi du travail à un moment où
deux bus tice est complètement à
réveiller avec la crise sanitaire
alors on sait qu'en 2019 le taux de
chômage chez les jeunes était de 13,6
pour cent un chiffre qui peut varier du
simple au double selon certains pays
l'organisation internationale du travail
redoute l'émergence d'une génération
confinement qui resterait en grande
difficulté pendant une décennie et ce
que vous partagez cette inquiétude
là on a comme élément de référence la
crise financière 2008 2009 dans
lesquelles il ya eu avec un peu moins
d'ampleur mais un phénomène du même type
avec une difficulté d'entrer dans le
monde du travail qui a abouti à ce qui
effectivement est là on a pu avoir des
études de suivi en particulier études
génération direct du monstre qu'il y a
eu effectivement un décalage d'entrer
dans la vie professionnelle qui a mis
plusieurs années à se résorber
même s'il a peu plus compliqué parce qu'
un certain nombre de jeunes saisissent
cette opportunité casion sur cette
obligation comme une opportunité
on voit des gens qui avaient prédit
jeunes avait prévu d'arrêter leurs
études et qui finalement décide de faire
une année supplémentaire plutôt que de
galérer pour trouver du travail
on en voit qui saisit l'occasion vers un
service civique parce que ça leur donne
une question veut découvrir un nouveau
monde cette occasion donc qui a un
contexte économique bien à côté lié à sa
vie personnelle sur le plan du travail
est ce que vous pensez que les jeunes
seront a marqué à vie par les effets de
cette pandémie
honnêtement c'est eux qui soucie
toujours qui ont fait référence à la
crise de 2008 2009 aujourd'hui les
choses ont été résorbés on pourra pas
dire que jusqu'à et la fin de leur vie
professionnelle ils sont marqués et par
cela tout dépendra de la rapidité et de
l'ampleur de la reprise économique qui
va ya voir si elle est relativement
rapide ça marchera pas si par contre
nous sommes durablement dans une
réduction de l'offre d'emploi c'est pas
les jeunes seulement qui sont marqués
parce que là aujourd'hui les jeunes ça
appareils patron bassil parce que c'est
le moment où ils rentrent sur le marché
du travail
mais vous avez aussi une difficulté très
forte sur les jantes sont plus âgés mais
qui n'ont pas de celui qui alterne des
petits boulots des périodes de chômage
et ceux là sont aujourd'hui dans la même
difficulté de jeunes avec en plus une
charge de fans iront les choses beaucoup
plus difficiles
est-ce que vous pensez que aujourd'hui
l'état pourrait venir en aide justement
à cette jeunesse ils disent oui il doit
le faire
on voit bien que il ya plusieurs aspects
sur lesquels la situation va être
difficile il ya finir les études pour
l'année en cours trouver des modalités
d'assouplissement
on a un certain nombre de formations qui
ont des stages obligatoires qui vont de
cursus et un certain nombre de ceux ci
n'ont pas pu se réaliser dans des
conditions normales
donc là on a trouvé les modalités qu'ils
ne soient pas qui permettent de valider
les cursus en cours
on nous en adaptant en tenant compte de
la crise mais plus qu'en 15 ans quand
même des trajets pour qu'on ne valorise
pas le diplôme donné qu'on n'aura pas
déçu donc là il ya vraiment au cas par
cas en fonction du temps à trouver
modalités de réalisation
la deuxième c'est effectivement de
trouver des modalités d'incitation aux
employeurs à faire deux choses à la fois
c'est là où c'est compliqué embaucher
les jeunes qui viennent dans une
information mais continuer à accueillir
des jeunes en apprentissage ou des
stagiaires qui ont besoin de cette
situation professionnelle pour se former
et donc il faut trouver un système
incitatif qu'ils ne fassent pas tout
pour une démesure tout pour les jeunes
qui viennent de vie dans leur formation
ou tout c'est qu'ils n'en fassent pas
une génération sacrifiée au détriment de
la suivre donc là on ya vraiment un
réglage à faire des mesures dead
puis il ya aussi à veiller à ce que les
mesures des deux soit différenciée en
fonction du niveau de formation il faut
gardien d'une priorité pour les jeunes
qui ont le plus faible niveau de
formation
sachant que la situation est difficile
pour tout le monde mais elle est quand
même moins mauvais des gens qui sortent
avec un bac +5 et une bonne formation
j'avais de ce qu'ils ont avec -5 très
bien merci beaucoup à tous qu'un michel
abhervé
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'économie sociale et de politiques
publiques et blogueur sur alternatives
économiques